it's monday morning you've just received
a voice notification from your voice
assistant
good morning there's a new pair of pants
on sale at your favorite store
last week while wearing your smart
glasses you were drawn to a similar pair
and a colleague would you like to wear
them to the party on thursday
i suggest you skip the movies tomorrow
night to afford them say yes to validate
the purchase
let me know if i should also find a gift
for your host i can make suggestions
based on your budget and her public
instagram profile
say yes to proceed
yes
so
thrilling
or
scary
because this is how our future could
look like very soon
as a working mom i find it exciting
i would love stop doing google searches
wasting time doing amazon scrolling
budget calculation or
optimizing my calendar
what is thrilling is the prospect of
having a companion that would cater
specifically to my needs and requests
just imagine it could do things like
using my heart rate to tweak my
starbucks order to reduce caffeine
it could take into account my lunch and
the number of steps i've walked to
tailor a workout for me
it could even align with my friends
smart assistants to craft evening plans
that would fit everyone's budget
calendars and locations
obviously this scenario could easily
lean towards the scary
this is why there needs to be regulation
in place
all users
all consumers should always remain in
full control of data they share
and on which type of recommendations
they agreed to get or not to get
now recommendation engines powered by
artificial intelligence are not new
far from it
we actually use them multiple times a
day already
on average
70 percent of the time spent on youtube
is on videos recommended by their
algorithm
and you may also own a wristband that
you use to track your sleep or
monitor your workouts
and there's the first generation of
voice enabled virtual assistants you
know like google home or amazon alexa
that you can use to change the
temperature of your room
your car as well is probably equipped
with
the same
things that can help you manage your
music or give you directions hands-free
but there is one thing that all these
tools have in common
they leverage ai
to help you in one specific area of your
life
your home
your car
your health
they stay in the lane
now
imagine a new generation of voice
assistants
that crosses all lanes
that synchronize
everything
so you may ask
why hasn't this happened already
because there are two technological
bricks that are critical to make this
happen that are still missing
one
is voice
these tools must be able to understand
everything we say
and clearly this is not the case today
for my kids maybe yours as well siri
is still an endless source of fun
they like asking very simple questions
and still get very confused answers
two
breadth
they must be able to provide a large
range of recommendations to cover
whatever we may need
so tech players are still working on
cracking those two elements voice and
breadth
on voice as i said
alexa
google home siri and the likes they
don't understand us entirely and
systematically for now
actually understanding human language is
difficult
it's as much about the context as it is
about the words themselves
and think about the accents or
background noise
it's already very difficult for
americans to understand
french people speaking english
so can you imagine how difficult it can
be for a robot
so tech players are working hard on this
in 2018 google launched an investment
program
for startups
that would work with their google home
suites
and since then they have invested in
over 15 companies
amazon has
10 000 employees
working on alexa voice technologies
so they will eventually crack the voice
issues
the smart assistants will be able to
understand what we say
the meaning of the words in their
context
for example
if i'm using my smart assistant and i'm
listening to music
and then i say change
hi karen do you want to change the
temperature of the room
well clearly this is not working yet but
in the future it will understand that
i'm talking about changing the track
not changing the temperature of the room
it will also understand our long and
complex requests you know when we start
saying something and then we change our
mind mid-sentence
but that doesn't stop here
with far field speech recognition you
will be able to use it from a distance
from a room to another
even with background noise like kid
screaming or traffic
tremendous progress has been made on
this recently largely due to amazon's
efforts on their echo speaker technology
not only that
it will be able to understand in which
mood you're in
joy
sadness annoyance and will be able to
mimic these feelings too
and
as natural language processing advances
further so natural language processing
is the technology behind this
so
as it advances further
the voice
enabled interactions will increasingly
be refined
now
the second challenge and the biggest in
my opinion
revolve around the breadth of
recommendations provided
will they be able to
uh what will be their range of actions
will they remain limited to very
specific tasks or will they be able to
become a true companion across your day
to which you can ask whatever you want
whatever you need
for example taking notes in a meeting or
reordering milk or even mental health
coaching
will they be able to provide your
recommendations
across
product categories
today
companies provide us recommendations
within
one specific category for example they
can help us choose between two dresses
between two books
in the future the smart assistants will
actually be able to help us choose
between buying a book or buying a dress
so to be able to deliver this
integrated and large range of
recommendations
tech teams behind smart assistants will
need to design the right algo algorithms
and these algorithms will need to be
powerful enough
to process a myriad of data points
to identify patterns to model courses of
actions
and also to learn from end users
feedback
but
a world where smart assistants become a
very unavoidable
means new priorities for all companies
not only the smart assistant players
every business in the future will need
to accelerate
drastically on data and algorithm
on voice enabled interactions
and also they will need to be entrusted
by consumers
to provide recommendations
this is why i like this is what i like
summarizing in three words in the three
imperatives that are data
tech
and trust
so
the moment
the breadth challenge and the voice
challenge get solved
will be a tipping point in smart
assistance usage and adoption by
consumers
today
can you live without your smartphone
i assume not right
in a few years from now your smart
assistant will become
will be a
convenient
powerful
reliable helper
essential in your day in your day-to-day
life
so you won't be able to live without it
and unlike your smartphones
it will be embedded in every device
around you your smartphone itself of
course but also your car
the mirrors
your fridge your glasses and who knows
what other device in the future
so
are you ready for a smarter life yes
karen i am
thank you
[Applause]